this is my quick guide to kitchen knives  basically three knives a heavy duty  chopping knife  followed by a small paring knife which  is brilliant for prepping vegetables  and then this baby here a serrated edge  knife for carving and slicing  basically that is it  [Music]  before you buy a knife hold it in your  hand and make sure it feels right for  you  the secret behind a great set of knives  is in the handle if you're comfortable  holding the handle  your cutting can be so much easier the  firmer the grip the better the chopping  the heavier the handle the more control  you've got over the blade  with these three knives you can't go  wrong